in the desert sands of Saudi Arabia a
fossil has just been found which fills a
crucial gap in the evolutionary history
of mammals including us
working together with the Saudi team
Laura McClatchy he adds omelette and
Phillip Gingrich at Ann Arbor and
Michigan couldn't believe their luck for
some years Philip had been looking in
this part of Saudi for fossil whales
presuming the area was in the sea in
Eocene period what we found looking for
whales was something completely
different
a team from the Saudi geological survey
where he adds guides and collaborators
yard had gone off to Saudi Arabia and we
said when you're out there look in the
tertiary deposits see what you can find
and you could walk over that fossil a
hundred times and not see it you have
really have to have sharp trained eye
have been in the field for a while a lot
of people would have walked over that
and thought I was just some scrap on the
surface and wouldn't have bothered to
look but whatever it was it was part of
a land mammal lying in what they thought
was a fossil rich seabed it should not
have been there I said well this is
going to be something exciting so I took
pictures I took some measurement and I
left the site as it is and disturbed I
put it an email and with couple of
pictures about the locality and send it
to an abra greg and i received an email
from him from the field
we've both opened the picture and we
were so excited about what we saw that
we ran into the hallway smack into each
other and said did you see that that's
the most extraordinary thing you can see
the email coming from Phil and Bill and
graving Jeff and everybody involved in
this project was like wow this is a
primate there are two main primate
groups the new world species such as the
squirrel monkey and the old world
monkeys and apes such as the gelada
baboon until now only one common
ancestor of both groups was known a
Caterine primate called Egypt epiphysis
here you can see primates with more
recent things at the top earlier ones at
the bottom and a gap early in what we
call cattorini the beginning of apes
just in here this is a big area of
uncertainty in primate evolution
when that fossil came back it was
immediately apparent that it's really
good phone really nice sediment that
comes off of the fossils very easily so
basically what the odd found was the
face of a very interesting primate and
you can see here there's one orbit one I
hope you will here's about the other
orbit
there's the forehead going up in this
direction here's the nose here there are
some front teeth incisor teeth here if
you flip it over I'll put it back down
here you can see a row of teeth here
here's a large canine and some molar
teeth from grinding teeth back here and
then this other little piece over here
actually is the ear region which
preserves some interesting details as
well so here was something wonderful and
you could see that it was very primitive
at the same time and that was exciting
then the next key for us was how old is
this what was known until now old world
monkeys apes are separate by the early
Miocene but how they connect to Egypt
OPA thickest and when they became
separate from Egypt opa fakers and new
world monkeys has been a big mystery the
new species was named sadhanas it's a
census a monkey found in this hedge as
region
if we look at the Paleo geography of the
African continent today its separated
from Arabia by the Red Sea but at the
time we're working in the Oligocene the
two were part of the same geography the
same final province I've been working in
fossil beds that are younger than this
since about 1994 very interested in
understanding about early ape evolution
and it's been frustrating in that our
fossil record is basically for Apes you
know goes back to about 21 million years
there's nothing prior to that part of
what's interesting about this is it is
not a monkey and it is not an ape humans
apes and old-world monkeys all share a
common ancestor this specimen would have
been very close to when Apes and overal
monkeys would have diverged from one
another very close and time and we think
also in anatomy to the morphology of the
common ancestor between old world monkey
and apes first question I ask people
like Yod when they find those fossils is
where is the rest of it you can see it
as a beautiful face the forehead is here
but the rest of the orbits the eye
sockets are missing if we turn it where
is the brain case so definitely we'll go
back and try to find more and better
specimens like this we have a blend to
open quarry and little paraty where
would find this primate
we think this publication is important
because it's a an important missing link
I know some people don't like that term
but I do like it because it fills a gap
in time fills a gap in form and it helps
tie things together that we weren't able
to tie together convincingly before this
is just the beginning